a lot of times when were you know on the
stage with libertarian candidates we
were agreeing with you guys with
libertarians more than we agreed
Democrats hi I'm Nick Gillespie with
Reason TV and today we're talking with
Kirsten kukauskas she's the press
secretary for the Republican National
Committee
Kirsten thanks for talking to us thank
you for having me why should a
libertarian a smaller libertarian a
believes in free market small government
lifestyle toleration gun rights why
should they vote for the GOP well I
think you just ticked off a lot of
things that are in our platform a lot of
a lot of issues from just smaller
government and obviously freedom liberty
all these things that we talk about here
at the RNC all the time we have a lot of
candidates a lot of great candidates
from Joni Ernst in Iowa to Cory Gardner
in Colorado who are out there talking
about these things every single day but
you also have on the opposing side you
have a Democrat Party that they have
spent the last six years under under
Obama pushing policies that are more
intrusive into our daily lives such as
Obamacare that that is probably the
singular biggest issue in terms of the
Democrats growing the size of government
that we've been very much against for a
very long but what I mean just to push
back a little bit though under Bush when
the Republicans held the White House the
Senate and the House of Representatives
federal spending went up about 50% over
the course of his two terms he busted
out the Patriot Act No Child Left Behind
the Department of Homeland Security
snuck us in two wars that we didn't pay
for and we didn't win
then there was tarp at the end why
should libertarians think that the
Republicans have learned a lesson yeah I
think I know a lot of those things we
have learned learned our lesson but also
I would say to your listeners and
viewers that times change things change
environments change I think that 9/11
was a very pivotal point for this
country and for a president and I think
that we we now in 2014 look at you know
look at the world as it was in 2001 2002
2003 in a very different light and so I
would just ask for people to remind you
know remind themselves but I think what
you've seen now is you've seen people
leaders on the hill whether it be you
know Rand Paul Ted Cruz you know people
who are out there every single day
keeping their the foot to the to the
fire on these Democrats and you know
even on people in our own party
reminding everybody hey we need to be we
you know we really need to be for
smaller government and these choices
really weren't what we needed as a
country and I also think that seeing the
Democrats overstep time and time and
time again since since President Obama
was elected I think has really reminded
us as a party just how bad this get this
can get and how we need to do we know
it's our role to bring it back I I think
you make a strong case that libertarians
shouldn't vote for Democrats but then
why shouldn't they vote for the
Libertarian Party or you know why should
you know the Republican Party on social
issues particularly things like gay
marriage and drug legalization
immigration abortion you know they tend
to be opposite kind of a broader and I
realized we can debate the definitions
but of freedom you know most
libertarians believe that the drug war
should and most libertarians are in
favor of abortion of being legal even if
they don't avail themselves of it is
there a sense that the Republican Party
is going to become more open to gay
marriage to drug legalization to issues
like that you know our party there are
some things we're probably not going to
agree on the libertarian party and in
the Republican Party I do think that the
world is very different than it was them
in the beginning of the 2000s I think
that our growth and opportunity project
report that came out in the beginning of
last year was very I think pivotal in
talking about how we can have be a big
tent party how we can have have
libertarians sitting in the same is it
you know under the same umbrella the
same tent as Republicans and I'll get
along and push forward policies that can
make our country better we have we have
the beliefs that we have we have we are
a you know we believe that marriage is
between a man and a woman we believe we
are a pro-life party but we need to do a
better job of talking about the reasons
that we are those things we believe in
those things but also of accepting
others for what
you know for their beliefs and how we
talk and you communicate with
individuals and Americans so that we are
not being judgmental and in having a
conversation that's off-putting to
Americans oh do you think beyond I mean
and that that would be a welcomed shift
in tone from a lot of Republican
rhetoric but is there a place of we
interviewed Rand Paul over the summer
and he talked about how for the
Republicans to win consistently at the
national level they really need to
become more of a live and let live party
is there a sense that the National Party
will say okay you know what let's let's
devolve a lot of these decisions whether
it's about the definition of marriage or
the legality of pot or other drugs to
the state level or will the Republican
Party always be socially conservative in
a way that will you know will in the end
whether or not you know we can talk I
mean that's gonna that's going to be a
real stumbling block between a
libertarian and conservative you know I
think that that is I think we're this is
gonna be an interesting conversation as
we head into a presidential year I think
you're gonna have a lot of people you
just mentioned Rand Paul you know who we
are they're going to start a
conversation in our party that's going
to be very interesting to be a part of
and to watch I can't tell you that you
know that we are going to change our
platform our platform is our platform
and I can tell you from being a part of
that process last time and seeing the
debates there are a lot of people in
this country that believe in what our
platform stands for but we do need to
understand that there are other
perspectives out there and we need to
have that conversation which I think
this party is is willing to have that
dialogue and I think 2016 is going to be
a very you know important year talk a
little bit about the Libertarian Party
and reason is not affiliated with but
the Libertarian Party among
conservatives and Republicans often is
cast in the terrible role of being a
spoiler and so say something like the
North Carolina Senate race but Sean ha
the Libertarian Party candidate is more
than covering the spread our do
libertarian party candidates spoil
elections for Republicans I think I
think it's the wrong way to look at it I
think that it provides a very good
conversation a very good contrast
between all of our ideas a lot of times
when were you
on the stage with libertarian candidates
we were agreeing with you guys with
libertarians more than we agreed
Democrats on a lot of things and I think
that that is a very good conversation to
have with voters and I think voters
appreciate that they don't want to look
at this in terms of you know white and
black and I think that it's a very good
thing to have that conversation I think
a lot of people sometimes you know I
think this has happening in both the
Democrat Party and the Republican Party
where we believe that a conversation is
threatening then conversation is very
good in these contexts well we will
leave it there thank you very much
Kristin cacao ski the press secretary of
the Republican National Committee thanks
so much for talking recent TV thank you